so this week we've had the Google thing
there was the YouTube thing that
happened last week
what's going on with censorship and what
should people do about it if you're in a
workplace and pathological things are
happening this is easy I can tell you
how you know if pathological things are
happening at your workplace or they're
happening with you one of the two but
you can straighten that out if you're
being required to do things that make
you weak and ashamed
then stop don't do them like one of the
things I learned from Solzhenitsyn and
Frankel was that systems go terribly
under out of control when people don't
stop them when they're going mildly out
of control you know when you might say I
should just keep my goddamn head down
and shut up it's like maybe you should
like that's not bad advice you know you
don't want to make unnecessary enemies
and you don't need any more trouble than
you need but you got to ask yourself on
a day-to-day basis what makes you think
you're not selling your soul you know
and there's so much foolishness going on
in the mid-level bureaucratic world now
that's where all the tyranny seems to be
focused and the reason that it
multiplies is because sensible people
say nothing when they should say
something and what's so strange about
that is that there are way more sensible
people than people who aren't sensible
they're just not as noisy so whether
you'll turn out if like you know so
let's say something's bugging the hell
out of you at work well then you have to
prepared it to find another job that's
the first thing you have to do I don't
think that you should find another job
but you should prepare to find another
job and if possible you should prepare
to find a better job because if you
can't tell someone to go to hell then
you can't negotiate with them and if and
if they've got you over a barrel then
you can't say anything so you going to
you got to set yourself up so you've got
some mobility and actually that's a
really good principle in your life
period
you should set yourself up so that you
have a lateral move at hand
and then you should find out well are
there things at work that are disturbing
my soul you know when you find that out
first of all you ask yourself okay I'm
disturbed at work okay I'm probably weak
and deceitful and useless and lazy you
might as well start with that and then
you talk to some people like your your
wife your friends your co-workers and
find out are you stupid deceitful and
lazy or is there something not-so-good
going on at work and so if you if you
can then eliminate your own personal
pathology as a cause of your
dissatisfaction then maybe there's
something rotten in the state of Denmark
and maybe you should say something about
it before the whole goddamn thing
collapses because that can happen it can
happen in companies a lot faster than
people ever think you know and you may
find that well first of all you may find
if you say something well first of all
that's an adventure that's for sure
that's a bloody adventure and you have
to do it carefully and you have to be
prepared for it it might be the best
thing that ever happened to you and the
other thing is if you're careful about
you get your words right like in this is
a this is strategic battle right it's
not something you wander into carelessly
then you may find that there's lots of
people who feel exactly the same way you
do and that you've actually caught and
on to something you're a canary in a
coal mine not just some like
psychopathic mouthpiece so you got to
ask yourself when you go and do what you
do like is this making you stronger is
this making you weaker and if it's
making you weaker then you got to ask
yourself do you really want to be weaker
because the weaker you get the more
you're terrorized and then worse than
that like the weaker you get the more
bitter you get and the more you'll work
towards terrible things the more you'll
snap at your wife the more you'll kick
your kids you know like it's no joke to
be terrorized at work and so I would say
you have an ethical responsibility as a
citizen to forthrightly confront
creeping tyranny no matter where it
occurs and part of part of what we're
learning I would say from these stories
if we're learning anything at all is
that if you're aimed at the good which
is a question you really got to ask
yourself you know if you're genuinely
aimed at the good then take heart
because you're a lot stronger than you
think so
I have a follow-up question okay so I'm
speaking to there's lots of people who
are in this situation like you know
people at universities and corporations
all over the place I you know Google is
not the only company that is no I'm not
the worst repressive freedom of speech
denying workplace codes and everybody
feels alone right they're all like why
should I stand up be a martyr get fired
this guy Google got fired yeah what's
the point
like I'm asking rhetorical no no it's a
good question and how do you how do you
convince people that there's a point to
standing up when it appears to be futile
well the first thing I think is you
convince them that it's not futile it
might be difficult but it's not futile
if you get your words right you have
something to say
there'll be an impact of those words it
might not be the impact that you would
choose but the other thing you got to
tell people is pick your poison
you don't you may be in a situation
where you don't have you don't have a
cake walk to the garden of paradise
you got tyranny or famine those are your
choices but you get to pick which one
you have and I would say if if you're
being oppressed and I mean in your soul
by what you're required to swallow at
work well you think you're not paying a
price for that you have no self-respect
and and rightly so but worse than that
you're an agent of your own destruction
you're destroying your own ideal and
you're letting people who are weak and
corrupt win and if you stood up and and
stood up property but you have to put
yourself in order to do this at least to
some degree right you can't do it
casually you have to do it from some
position of preparedness and strength
then what makes you think you couldn't
scare them back into the corners and
that would be a good thing and you know
the alternative personally is bad
because
is a psychological degeneration that
goes along with it I've seen this with
many many of the people that I work with
who have been terrorized in the
workplace to the absolute detriment of
their psychological and physical health
right to the point of collapse
confronting these crazy crazy things
when there are sensible people that's a
terrible price to pay man like it's it's
a bad price and then if the foolishness
isn't dealt without the local level when
it's still relatively trivial then it
will multiply until it's dealt with at
the social level and we're seeing signs
of that already antiphon of that you
know and problems that aren't solved
multiply and soon people fight and you
know editor to argue then to fight
unless you want to fight and some people
want to fight and I can understand why
but I wouldn't recommend it because that
doesn't lead good places
it really doesn't lead good places so
I'd say you have a duty maybe that's
that's where you stand up it's because
you have a goddamn duty to stand up and
say just say what you have to say if you
don't even have to be trying to make a
point exactly or trying to get something
done it's like this is how it looks to
me that's what that guy at Google did he
wrote this memo and he said I talked to
him today said well he went to a
diversity training seminar and he
thought no I don't agree with that and
so then they asked for feedback so we
wrote this document a month ago this was
written a month ago got no real response
to it but bounced around inside Google
until a lot of people you know got
interested and then it escaped into the
outside world but all he was doing was
he was told a bunch of things he didn't
think were true he wrote down a bunch of
things he thought were probably true he
launched that out and said well I think
these things are probably true it's like
well probably they're true well so he
paid a price for it but maybe we'll see
what sort of price he paid for it man
it's going to be a lot tougher in two
years than he was two years ago so
no they didn't answer his feedback
no no but well you can watch the video
the story's there but that's kind of the
outline of it so sorry to monopolize
this so I have one other question about
this and I think it's important
aside from Google just being a workplace
right it also controls the own YouTube
right yeah which in orderto it's the new
sensor surface game and it controls a
huge amount of the information that
people get then through and so what
happens to society when companies such
as Google was control our information
start to censor not just how about
themselves and and maybe the information
that's coming out to the rest of the
world how much is this already happening
and how much how about if we what
happened how about if we refuse to find
out that would be good you know like I
reviewed this this guy's document I did
that yesterday and everything he said
was validated by the scientific
literature so what has happened is that
someone has been fired publicly by major
corporation for stating well-grounded
scientific truths right there are
exactly the sorts of things that I say
in my classes for example and the reason
that I say them is because I read the
literature it's not because I'm
personally happy about the facts I think
IQ research particularly is so dismal
that you can't possibly read it without
being seriously disheartened if I could
reconstruct the world so that IQ the IQ
research wasn't true well it'd sure be
tempting you know but that's not how
science works science doesn't tell you
what you what you want to hear it just
tells you the way it bloody well is and
he got pilloried for he got pilloried
for revealing a good fraction of current
scientific knowledge about gender
differences okay that's not good and as
you said that's a big company and it
controls our communication how about we
do
what we can to ensure that these large
communication companies don't get to
impose a factually false ideological
structure on the rest of the planet or
you could think about supporting this
this guy who blew the whistle there's a
fundraiser for him online he could use
some money he wants to sue Google yeah
you know maybe we could maybe we could
let them know that hiring a human
resources director who's also concerned
with equity is probably not a good idea
for capitalist company why in the world
would you hire your own enemies I don't
understand that so well we'll see how
the dialogue continues but back to the
personal like you need to say what you
think because that's where you come from
right and if you don't say what you
think then you kill your unborn self
that's what you do that's what Cain did
when he killed Abel and that's why his
punishment was unbearable you know you
have things in you that are struggling
to come to the light that's the truth
you need daughter and you need to either
that truth because without that truth
you cannot live in the world because the
world is real and you need truth to live
in the world and if you stifle your
truth well how how can that be anything
but something that brings about hell how
could it be any other way
so you think well why should you speak
up that's easy because the consequences
of not speaking up although delayed are
far worse that's the reason that's the
reason if it can't be courage it could
at least be prudence so yeah
[Applause]